meanwhile there is the race policy that
will undoubtedly follow this
administration we've already seen it
implemented at the local level
the biden administration has repeatedly
suggested that equity is to guide all of
its decisions as we have talked about at
length on this program
when folks on the left say equity they
do not mean equality what they mean
is that any program that does not
achieve equal outcome
on the basis of group any program that
does not achieve that is considered
racist and to be anti-racist whenever
you see somebody saying
i'm doing the work i've become an
anti-racist it doesn't mean i've become
a not racist
it means i have become a person who
wants to tear down all existing
structures of power
castigating them as systemically
discriminatory
right that's what it means so this is
the stuff that the biden administration
has been pushing they've been pushing it
in vaccine policy they've been pushing
an educational policy they've been
pushing an economic policy and
environmental policy they literally said
that ibrahim x kennedy's idea of how the
world should work is the way they are
going to govern
which is scary as all hell because first
of all in many cases it is violative of
the basic principle of the civil rights
act of 1965 which is that people ought
not be treated on the basis of group or
race they ought to be treated instead on
the basis of their individual identity
instead this is not what is happening
and we are seeing it crammed down
in our educational system primarily so
christopher ruffo
who writes for a city journal and he is
uh the director of a of a group called
discovery
the center on wealth and poverty at
discovery institute
so he has been keeping track of the woke
equity politics that is now being
mainlined into our educational system so
take a take a gander at this
chris ruffo tweets out the principal of
east side community school in new york
sent white parents a tool for action it
tells them they must become
white traitors and then advocate for
full white abolition
okay this is nuts so let's take a look
at this for just a second because
while the while the biden administration
i keep mixing them up because this is
just obama administration part three
because the biden administration
has embraced the basic equity playbook
here
this is what they mean they haven't gone
all the way yet but they will don't
worry we're very very early on
so they have been distributing at the
school the eight white identities by a
person named barnor hess
and and the eight white identities
stretch from white supremacist in the
red
to white abolitionist in the green
they say there is a regime of whiteness
and there are action-oriented white
identities
people who identify with whiteness are
one of these it's about time we build an
ethnography of whiteness
since white people have been the ones
writing about and governing others
okay what the hell does any of that mean
well let's get a little more specific
here are the eight white identities
according to barn or hess
again this is being taught now at
schools in new york
and by the way at schools that are
liberal in la same kind of thing
you're gonna see this brought into
public education with a vengeance over
the course of the next few years okay
that's the prediction
here are the eight white identities
according to barnard has
he says one white supremacist right
these are the worst people and this is
what
all of american society is clearly
marked white society that preserves
names and values white superiority that
makes it you're white supremacist okay
second white voyeurism wouldn't
challenge a white supremacist desires
non-whiteness because it's interesting
and pleasurable
seeks to control the consumption and
appropriation of non-whiteness
fascination with culture example
consuming black culture without the
burden of blackness so if you listen to
rap but you're white
this means that you're probably a white
voyeurist you're a white voyeur
right you're not a white supremacist but
you're kind of white supremacist
adjacent
because you're like a white supremacist
and that you like all the structures of
power but you also like listening to rap
music then there's white privilege
maybe you critique supremacy but a deep
investment in questions of fairness and
equality
under normalization of whiteness and the
white rule sworn goal of diversity so
now if you say that you like diversity
but you also believe in things like
fairness and equality on an individual
level
this means that you are suffering from
white privilege because of course the
entire system
is white and so if you say that you want
everybody to be treated equally on an
individual level this means you're
upholding
a system that has been supremacist in
the past in his supremacist today so
you're actually just privileged
okay then fourth level this is all this
is all called crap by the way this is
just cultic nonsense
fourth level okay now we are rising so
we went from the worst and
we're moving toward the best get ready
for it gang fourth white benefit
you're sympathetic to a set of issues
but only privately you won't speak or
act in solidarity publicly because
benefiting
through whiteness in public some people
of color are in this category as well
so this would be like candace owen so if
you're a black person but
you don't speak in or act in solidarity
with
whiteness in public uh or
against whiteness in public this means
that you're a voip benefit actually
according to these folks candace is
probably a white supremacist maybe a
white voyeurist
same thing for shelby steele a white
benefit person is a person
who um is actually a black lives matter
sympathizer but doesn't speak out very
loudly about it then there's white
confessional
okay white confessional is some exposure
of whiteness takes place but as a way of
being accountable to people of color
after
you're seeking validation from people of
color okay so this is all the people who
marched
in the black lives matter protests but
are white who posted a black square on
instagram
you're a white confessional because you
can see your own whiteness
but you're only seeking validation from
people of color now you might think to
yourself okay like
that should be about as radical as it
gets here you're basically saying that
the system you're you're conceding all
the points don't worry there's more
white critical now we're getting to the
people who are reaching saintly levels
of anti-whiteness white critical you
take on board critiques of whiteness and
invest in exposing or marking the white
regime
you refuse to be complicit with the
regime whiteness speaking back to
whiteness this is white people telling
other white people that they are too
white
because why do you make white white make
white white okay finally
you can be a white trader you actively
refuse complicity you
name what is going on your intention is
to subvert white authority and tell the
truth at whatever cost
you need them to dismantle institutions
and finally you're a white abolitionist
this is like the highest level
you have you've cleansed yourself of all
sin you have purged yourself your full
robin deangelo
white abolitionist you change
institutions you dismantle whiteness
you don't allow whiteness to reassert
itself but by the way what's amazing
about this is that you're still the one
in power right you're the white person
who's in power
and you're acting on behalf of people of
color you are now a white abolitionist
okay this is the crap they are teaching
to school children it's racist nonsense
there should be lawsuits on the basis of
this but get ready this sort of stuff is
going to be mainlined into american
politics
because as soon as you start using the
term equity this is where it's going we
all know this is where it is going
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional leftist
tier
don't ask me why that's called science
to take advantage of this amazing
opportunity
hit the like button